this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
welcome to your sunset Safari today and
of course we mister Hosanna and I am
Warren and on camera today I have Davi
now we've came them to the usual spot
Sano's usual hangout where he was this
morning and of course he ups and moves
around did to toilet and he's
repositioned himself right back down in
the shade by his favorite pan in the
world now this episode is brought to you
by Metamucil and we need you to talk to
us so please do use the hashtag Safari
live and talk to us on Twitter or on the
YouTube chat stream send in your
questions or any comments we are seeing
in front of us so it wasn't exactly hard
to find Hosanna because he was exactly
where he was left this morning he's
definitely a lot easier than Tandy I had
my work cut out for me this morning very
happy that I got to spend some time with
the Queen however it was no easy task
that's for sure and the weather this
afternoon is absolutely risers and thick
socks in anticipation for the coldness
that will come out tonight when we're on
our TV show however I'm slightly
regretted my choice at the moment as we
sit here and bake in the Sun so I'm sure
Hosanna is also feeling extremely hot in
the Sun with that thick coat of fur that
he has but what he likes to do he likes
to be tucked away in the vegetation get
in the Xi's and the cool the coolness
but he likes to have his eyes he like
his eyes pop and outs his sort of look
around and watch everything that goes
past in terms of other wildlife and
Pallas in Yala's anything that goes past
he likes to be able to watch everything
from a vantage point and many of your
call me
in that it looks like a lovely sunny day
and indeed it is which I'm not
complaining about at all but sometimes
when you have to stare into the Sun it
doesn't make life very easy but I'm not
complaining at all it's deliciously warm
and it's so good to actually feel some
warmth by the time we go out for our
sunrise Safari it's rather chilly on all
levels coffee gloves and scarves are
essential so of course it really isn't
just me out today there are others so
let's go across to Steve and see what
he's up to
good afternoon everybody well we're also
looking into the Sun at the moment my
name is Steve joined by Craig on camera
so apologies for my hat being so load
down but we are following up on er the
uncle Homer pride from this morning and
then when we get in there we'll just
turn around so the sun's behind us look
into it if they're in the same place I
got a pretty strong feeling they should
be in the same place but you never know
lions do move and if they do move we're
gonna have to try and track them again
and hopefully we'll be as easy as it was
this morning because this morning was
one of the easier attempts are tracking
a pride of lions
but for now they have moved which is
kind of expected to wear though is the
question now I got them again James the
cats have been kind and well they are
here they just we'll just keep moving
into shady but as the day goes so when
they're in an area like this it's not
that well vegetated they'll just keep
moving with the Sun keep moving and keep
moving
they were here this morning and then
they're here and then by the time we
left over there and now they're about 30
meters more to the right very good
the objective was to find them to know
that they're in the same place we do
have TV this afternoon so we would like
to find a character for trehala
so once we get in the end just establish
the sighting we will probably get Bob
see that was a little bit of a black
monkey orange they are a formidable
encroaching species which Rickson and
his habitat team or cutting out but so I
don't feel too bad
smashing them from time to time because
they are encroaching as I said okay I'm
just gonna pull over on the side yeah
so we can show everybody the Lions first
before we go over to Trish let's just
show everybody that we do in fact have
some lions yeah and then once we've done
that then by all means Emma we'll send
everybody over to Trish to say good
afternoon but just a quick hello and
Goomer pride there you are
in the shade of a leafless marula tree
very good they'll be here for some time
so Craigan are probably gonna stay here
for maybe a segment if we need to or
second one and then we go off and help
Patricia track but in the meantime
Shoshana has headed off towards the west
let's go and say good afternoon to her
hello everyone
Marcella and I are very well my name is
a tree shala with Marcel on memo for the
weekend and we've been having some good
eating so this good luck going around
like Steve said we will be finding a
notice we all have something super
special now I myself I'm just coming up
north along the northern boundaries just
on my left and I'm gonna sniff around
yeah
and hopefully of your hobbies spend time
with him like I was lucky to spend the
morning with one day she got together
with him instead it's nothing oh I'm so
sorry sorry about my horrible breakup
but I'm gonna go to the den soon let me
send you over to Steve in the meantime
er with those live well sorry about that
everybody I don't know what's going on
with Trish I think she's so full of
energy this afternoon that she is giving
off all sorts of weird signals to the
camera and the signals are causing the
gremlins to attack they Dart
you didn't miss anything while you're
away from us for that minute that minute
and the Lions are still here and I'm
certain they will be yep for the next
two hours well we hope they'll be here
for the next three and a half hours as
is always the case five minutes before
TV now get up and walk out but we are
about eight hundred yards from the
southern boundary but a kilometre from
the western boundary and the northern
boundary is probably about three
kilometres north so we are in a good
spot if they do decide to go north well
at least you be able to catch them for a
fair amount of that time if they do walk
through no doubt on the path that
they're on now probably head up towards
the open areas of quarantine to try and
harass the have all the beasts heard
that likes to to hide out there or the
many many Impala and we find out on the
open plains there and they have been a
couple of Zebras around the last couple
of days but they seem to come in to Juma
and then out again without remaining for
very long whatever it might be
food that will get them kuma pride
moving
well maybe the needs to drink because it
has been a relatively warm day today of
28 degrees Celsius I'm sorry I forget
the Fahrenheit now
definitely the warmest time of winter
hello sir Maya you want to know where
this is happening we are in Duma in the
sabi sands South Africa on the western
fringes of the greater Kruger National
Park and a province called them Puma
langa about seven hours east as the crow
flies from Johannesburg by vehicle about
an hour and 20 minutes in a plane and
Superman would probably take about 15
minutes a Craigie to get jet from
jo'burg Craig's not sure
Craig anywhere Superman pajamas he
doesn't know more about him hey Craig
how many jakey
I'm giving Craig a hard time this
afternoon because I'm going to leave
tomorrow
giving Craig a hard time because I got
an even the morning and so you've got to
get all the things out that you want to
say to everybody before you leave so
they don't miss you too much so we are
in the wilderness of the great - Kruger
National Park the sabi sands is a sixty
thousand hectare property that adjoins
the western side of the Kruger Park it
has been private property for probably
about 80 years or so and it has been at
Wilderness sorts of ecotourism area for
about sixty of those years as Paul
actually been in private property for
longer than that I'll forget exactly
when it was privatized but for about 60
odd years 70 years maybe even getting
there people have been trying to conduct
wilderness sort of events and this is
where it all started in southern Africa
from a game drive point of view and film
documentaries point of view
and this pride of lions those of you who
are new to our screens is called the
uncle Homer pride which is named after a
beautiful tree called the brown ivory
which in Shangaan is called brown re M
kuma and this pick all the viewers say
you feel like this on a warm day well
indeed the Lions are rather warm and I
was discussing this morning that it's
the shade and the trees that the shadow
tree in the shade the trees provide that
allow such diversity of mammals in this
ecosystem some animals can avoid the Sun
by going underground you can imagine
lions going in the ground you'd have to
get some really big burrows I've seen
leopards go into big holes in the ground
I've never seen a lion going deep into
the ground I have seen them digging to
get warthogs but I've never seen them
physically go in but in a buffalo as
well they can't go into the shell and
two holes all the best giraffe so many
many adaptations have evolved Archer to
allow animals to survive in these harsh
climates Oh
Craigie there's a woodpecker just landed
up there it's moved if I spot him I'll
let you know that marilla tree is
looking a little bit worse for wear
behind it's looking like it is a wood
Pickers dream
lots of bark falling off there is far
right can you see em craggy far at
lowest branch there or medium branch
that one sticking out there we go would
pick up searching for that's a golden
tail yeah female golden tail looking for
some grabs some beetle larvae inside the
wood wood-boring beetles will deposit
their eggs inside the wood and massive
big larvae in grubs will actually grow
inside eating
would themselves okay well she's found
that tree to be unsatisfactory and has
now moved off the tree is still
providing shade although I think it is
going to die soon I don't know why maybe
I'm completely mistaken
very good
are we going to move off after this and
see if we can help Trish find another
leopard or something and while we do
that let's go over to the lady herself
I look I'm not a picture broken up isn't
that wonderful because the last thing I
want is gremlins trying to attack me
definitely not not tonight anyway we are
heading down to the hyena den I'm gonna
just check up on them see it what
they're up to
hello you guys nothing like a few doves
in the road remember we were talking
about dog tracks in the road they're
always walking in front of us we pointed
them out in bushwalk I think once
luckily for them they move out of there
the way quick enough most of the time
I'm glad to say I haven't hit a bird
now I am looking about for birds as well
because oh so this morning is bird that
we were looking at I a good look at a
good Oh Cal six your wondering if David
Attenborough has ever been there - Juma
Cal six that day I think well I don't
know what I'll do but he has not been to
Juma but I would I don't I would I don't
know what I'd do if he did come to gym I
definitely want to take him on Drive but
then I also wouldn't what to take him on
Drive
but he hasn't been to Juma but he's
welcome to come to Juma if you are
watching this David Attenborough but I
was talking to you about it this morning
his bird the eagle that we saw for you
and I will show you so I was not sure at
the time and always been there's
juvenile Birds it can be a little bit
more difficult and I have now oh I am
now satisfied that it is a juvenile Tony
Eagle as some of you had said actually
so good on you I just want to show you
quickly as soon as I find it Tony Tony
where are you
so this is what I was looking at on that
bed that made me believe that it is a
juvenile 20 eagle so that's the
individual that we know there we go
we are looking at these this group down
yes so you can see there's quite a bit
of variation that goes on and when they
are juvenile they're sort of gaining
some coloration and losing others so
what the individual we had still saw
sort of had adult brownie head but the
rest of it was still kind of pale and it
had all these very nicely feathered feet
faded legs down there so we knew it was
a true eagle and it had a nice long gape
and I got to see that from your
screenshots so I think it is a juvenile
tawny eagle I'm sure if you agree with
me please them you know if not let me
know also and if you do think it's
something else
hashtag safari live and tell me but your
screen shots were really really helpful
with that
and I think I did I think I did let me
see I think I did save a picture of one
and that looked a lot like ours there we
go so this one I thought that this so
this is a juvenile Tony and I thought it
looked very much like the individual we
saw today brown head but the body is
still whitish also has a peel band over
here can you see that so that's why I
was pretty convinced I saw a number of
these yes getting nice and tight there
myself
all righty well that is it you do know
of course you know I in the meantime
we'll head down to the hyena den and see
if there's any obviously hyenas around
and also a mongoose and maybe that honey
badger I always get excited to go back
to the same place because you think
maybe just maybe those animals will be
there again
I am going to be there in 15 minutes I
think with all the stopping and checking
of tracks etc etc so I'll see you just
now in the meantime I'll send you over
to Lauren and she is she pottering about
I'm not sure she's still with us on a
please not sure it's good well so much
for me seen that husana was happy
sleeping and enjoying the Sun because
ever since you left us farm might I add
but he's literally moved from sort of
vegetation to log to very small termite
mounds where he is right now and as he
moves is hilarious he goes into stalking
moon where he puts his body very very
low to the ground and of course his
shoulder blades come right up and what
he's trying to do I think is there is
impala upper heads and he's just trying
to get closer and closer to them they
are some distance off in this direction
I can't even really see them but he's
just slowly making his way there and
keeping us low to the ground as possible
so that they don't get any wind of him
if you like as soon as they do and Paula
as you know are very very vocal and they
will of course tried to stand up to him
and that's exactly what he's trying to
avoid so he's not actively hunt and act
a minute but what he's doing he's put
himself and praying because there we go
a little groom
he's just putting himself in prime
position trying to use any sort of cover
that he can find and Davi just gave you
a view of what we're looking at and it's
actually quite thick the grass is long
here and there's a lot of trees but I
can see two Impala Rams walking closer
and closer just or here and they haven't
seen him but he's definitely seen them
[Music]
we have a question did he get anything
to eat this morning or last night I have
no idea I'm afraid absolutely no idea
and we didn't see him hunt anything so
and we can't vouch for that I imagine he
would have snacks along the way
potentially on a scrub here or something
small but it doesn't look like you made
a big kill could it that way but he
potentially could have smacked along the
way throughout the evening but of course
we didn't see that happen so we can't
vouch for it but I do believe he made a
hunt or a field hunt should I see it was
captured on the dam cam and it's rather
endearing he stalks an Impala who's
taking a drink for quite a long time and
every time the Impala moves his head he
freezes just like musical statues and of
course as he gets closer the Impala gets
away it's very very sweet so I don't
personally feel he did make a kill last
night
but once again we can't vouch for that
so he's not actively hunting at the
minute but he knows the impala are there
and he knows he's got to keep himself
low to the ground he's watching them in
family hosana loves watching everything
when he's got his eyes open of course he
can barely keep them open at the minute
it's like I'm gonna have a mini tiny
snooze and keep opening my eyes just to
check where these Impala are and he
hasn't yeah he's got shade he's right
next to these mums which I imagine would
be quite cool and he's got a sort of
shrub fish in front of him so he has got
cover but of course Impala are experts
at spotting the Predators coming we
heard impala barking everywhere today at
Sandy they were coming from all sorts of
directions I'm just checking
we're obviously at the end of the
rutting season now but these two males
I've just got they're fighting oh no
they've just gone behind the bush
but they're actually fighting and what
that means is that they're not paying
attention to what's going on around them
which is exactly what husana wants
predators fully make use of the rutting
season because the mains are paying more
attention so they're sort of sexual
health and their dominance and winning
over females and battling it out with
the meals that they're actually not
paying attention for predators and they
actually use them lose muscle condition
become quite weak because they're also
not eating properly they're fighting I
think we've got the love they keep horn
clashing with one another you see that I
don't pain any attention to what's going
on one of them's walking backwards
Oh silly Rams if obviously so got some
testosterone on in them and driving for
damp dominance this one's walking
backwards
Oh boys you're getting closer and closer
one of them's got an ox pecker on his
back and this is exactly what Impala do
they don't pay attention
these Rams are still Horned passion one
of them does appear a little bit more
alert than the other goodness it's all
happening in front of me right now
they're too busy trying to see who's
bigger who's better who's the more
dominant one that they don't like sauce
columns right there
oh we just had a snorer
I was a bit strained he's not looking at
hosannas direction trying to keep my
eyes on everything at the minute sorry
why is Nora oh oh this one's runnin
right in his direction they don't know
he's they are they feel that something's
there but they don't know what is they
are I think he was utterly bewildered by
that situation as well he's like what
just happened
the Impala I believe did not actually
see him I don't feel the Impala looked
in his direction
well the males have stopped fighting one
way in one direction the other one the
other direction so they strive for
dominance and who's better than who is
obviously over and Prasanna looks
utterly bewildered the in power almost
ran right into him that's how much they
were not paying any sort of attention
there I'm sorry boy but it all happened
a bit too fast for you
he's saying come on Hosanna yes no boy
but you know what he probably wasn't
ready for a leopards have to be in
control normally when they're hunting
they are of course stalkers and they
generally like to stock up on their prey
so that probably that just take him by
surprise cuz he's two impalas came out
no we are started fighting one was
walking backwards and all of a sudden
they walked right past him so he
obviously was not ready for it and any
way shape or form and it is extremely
hot right now I think he is just
watching this is his domain in quiche
just keeping his eye on what's gone on
he loves fortune what's going on but he
definitely missed an opportunity there
oh dear dear dear of course we're gonna
stay here with Hosanna and see exactly
what happens next because you never know
what this boy and while we do that we're
gonna send you back across the steep we
have left the Lions you're just gonna
bumble around a little bit and check
give Trisha a little bit of a hand
someone is on their way to the Lions
there okay so this is where some of them
came from this morning
the tracks along the road yeah this is
an area where they often come in from
the south
the shabam or dense ice road well this
is cheb Army Road which actually means
firearm rifle because the marriage makes
the noise ababil a lot of local words
actually relate to the sound that they
make remember this is the dead sides
over here where who Komori led us to
that one day and we had so much joy with
June in her Cubs wasn't that incredible
I haven't really been using it too much
since
but the Lions came straight in from here
in the south but I'm just gonna
double-check that whatever leopard that
was that came down this morning cuz I
was tracking a leopard then I found Lion
tracks far more lion tracks found the
Lions not really the young lions are
still regarded a sub-adult
the females will start sort of
contributing to the breeding now they
actually would be breeding ready now and
I think one of they might even be in
East rasam not sure I know Jamie was
saying that it seemed like one of the
youngsters was actually was actually
pregnant last time but I didn't notice
anything today
with any of the younger ones but the
males you know they they stopped too
young to really get in the way of mating
and to be dominant so they're not really
regarded as adults yet so generally
about three years they've sort of then
reached that stage when they're really
induction to the pride males quite often
get chased away then they
live a life of a nomad until they become
big and strong enough to compete for the
breeding and mating success in other
prides but the females will definitely
be contributing soon it's not that the
males aren't able to mate it's that they
won't be allowed to just like wasana
everyone was saying last year everyone
was wondering could he mate Willy mate
Kenny mate you know any young animal or
young individual can mates it's whether
they're allowed to mate and with lions
and leopards they don't really want to
allow a youngster to mate because of the
fact that if a youngster mates with a
net with a female and she has cubs
there's no chance that youngster is
going to be able to protect her protect
her and her cubs and the territory so
they're generally go for big dominant
males who haven't established themselves
in the area but male lion is generally
considered an adult from about for a
little while ago four years of age and
in their prime 5 6 7 prime prime prime
but if they're in a big coalition they
can be dominant a danger for if they're
in a big coalition they can actually be
dominant age of 3 if there are lots of
if they're in a big coalition never too
late some coalition males are format and
then leave for sure we had a pride in
the Kruger that had nine young males one
end up getting killed by coalition of
five and there were nine and at three
they were just formidable and three
years old there's an eight of them eight
and imagine trying to compete with eight
you just don't know where to look to you
so it's possible for them to form a
coalition earlier it's one of the
reasons why Lions mate or synchronous to
keep breed so that they can have enough
recruits into the pride for hunting
number one they can community suckle
number two and if they have a sex ratio
of 50/50 which is generally the case
those males can say there's so there's
ten cups in father male and five survive
five males survive then those five could
form a coalition and move off
take the genetics of this pride away
with them to another pride so that's one
of the other sort of added benefits of
of synchronistic breeding which is quite
quite interesting in lions we've seen it
down in the hyenas but it doesn't work
the same sort of way
my ears have all been breeding at the
same time but there's huge hierarchy and
as we know generally the Cubs inherits
their rank of their mums whereas lions
don't really have that sort of hierarchy
sort of thing if you're big enough to
feed eats as much as you can okay well
Shoshana is on the search still let's go
see if she's had any luck catching up
with any Highness well I'm in the right
block and I'm actually approaching the
den that's most news now ahead of us
just past the what I call ribbons usual
spot or who used to be one of her
favorite past-time spots but I really
hope that they around I really like to
see June's to you as well which would be
a treat I think there used to be a crazy
Mongoose that used to live on this mound
right yeah and I say crazy because it
actually had a Alice you'd like to know
which one of pretties cubs are in the
beylin which one is Swasey I will tell
you in a moment just look at the crazy
mound from the crazy crazy Mongoose and
you can see my my shadow hello shadow
but pretty scabs so pretty has two cubs
and she has a male and a female so the
male is Swasey that helps you out a lot
easier because also Swasey sounds a bit
more masculine at least in my opinion
nobody's home and becoming upset coming
here so often having nobody be at home
but it's okay I will come back and check
periodically because I find especially
nowadays it seems that it's the time it
can be it's almost as if you can you
can't count it she can to tell they're
gonna be in and in the beginning or in
the morning or in the evening it's the
Sun setting you can't tell anymore so
you've just got to keep on popping in
and hoping that that she'll be lucky and
they'll come round they seems to be a
lot of movement within the Juma clan
these days
don't want to lose myself there we go
huh scenic you'd like to know why is it
only wild dogs and hyenas that have a
hierarchy I think when you're speaking
about the hierarchy it's more for highly
specialized social structure because
hierarchies exists all over all through
nature they exist in termites bees they
exist even within buffalo herds that's
still a bit of a hierarchy going on so
it's just as if groups like hyenas have
really really specialized that whole
social system another interesting one of
course are baboons with an oligarchy
which basically is a few individuals
have a particular influence based on
their relationships and things like that
between people between individuals but
the whole idea of having a system where
or a very intricate social system is
very very interesting so as you know i'm
tristan told you that he was looking for
eyes for me so I've been reading quite a
bit about eyes and you might think how
can the social structure of an animal be
linked to its eyes or to vision
it's amazing how all these things are
linked to but having binocular vision so
we had eyes in the front care for myself
right we have eyes in the front of our
heads which means that offers us by
knocking division by an ocular vision so
depth perception but in so doing we lost
the ability to have this overall vision
so now we became kind of vulnerable
because of the vision when I say we I
mean mammals that evolved to have fun
television and then due to the fact that
we couldn't see all around us anymore
living in groups became really
beneficial because it meant that
everyone could have a look out and then
the living in groups was really
beneficial so now you're living together
your eyesight is better because you can
be focused and you have this front fold
facing eyes that are well-developed and
now you are starting to recognize little
things within your group you sign in to
build relationships you starting to see
features and expressions and that's how
social structures all sort of sort of
develop from that idea because now it
becomes an arms race your visions
getting better
your visual cues that you can pick up on
the on the Oh someone's asking about the
higher unit in respond to them in a
moment but that whole idea of now I've
got to see or now I can interpret
people's feelings based on the
expressions a lot better and then vision
becomes better because that trait
becomes something that's good quality
because now you can better respond to
people based on or animals or your kin
based on your visual cues so that whole
social structure has actually risen out
of this binocular vision which is just
mind-blowing but it gives you a good
idea about the intricacies of all things
that are nature and the way there are
all kind of ties together not kind of it
does try together
exactly our Larimore you have to watch
each other's backs
and by watching each other's backs
something else comes in now you may have
the ability to deceive and maybe your
ability to deceive has a visual cue and
maybe that visual cue helps people see
if someone is lying or something is
lying and something's trying to deceive
them so it's just snowballs it's a
snowball of we can see better we're
getting more cues I said it's getting
better and it's just it's almost like we
have to keep up with each other and
maintain that this contact maintain
these social bonds all because of the
position of our eyes pretty neat I think
anyway I've checked the dens like we saw
them and they are not around but we can
keep on moving a little bit west oh well
let's go over to Steve while I keep on
bounding about sure because his pupils
must be very very small with the Sun in
his eyes well really struggling I was
struggling because the Sun was in my
eyes but now I've turned the corner and
everything's fine so I find that very
interesting social standing through our
sights obviously plumage as something
that's very incredible with birds birds
had form these legs so males that
display and dance and get colourful long
tails whatever it might be you can look
at them as a human you could probably
capture a lot of them you could weigh
them you could measure them you could do
everything you want to you won't be able
to see a difference between them but the
lady's standing on the outside watching
those guys dance watching them perform
we'll time in and Tom again pick the
same male did off to the side they'll
have a mate he'll come back in the
middle of his little Center and he'll
dance again I find that incredible but
fast we can't see can't see the
difference
social standings through our sites is
probably maybe it's the that the male
secures through dominance he secures a
middle splattery secures the best area
whatever it might be
I find it fascinating and obviously all
most of the birds that do that are
polygamists which means that they'll
mate - there's many females as they
possibly can and those layer ladies will
choose him because of something special
about him
with long tails they call the handicap
hypothesis if the guys still alive with
this enormous tail and plumage he's the
man for me or if he's got some very
specific dance the birds of paradise
from Madagascar blow me away if you've
never seen anything like that before you
should check it out the birds of
paradise they are incredible how far
those guys have gone to to impress
ladies and it's the same as with Weaver
nests and with long tails and with
dances it's very very picky females that
have led to this evolution of
unbelievable displays in the bird
Kingdom incredible okay so anyway we've
checked treehouse damn we don't have any
tracks coming down there so we're just
gonna go down a chick twin dams area and
see if we can find any sort of sign of
Tunney and then I'm gonna go and check
the bat aliyah-din
that I found that all the site I found
so my n is that the other day just to
double-check that people have been
checking in the right spot because it's
possible that they haven't I know Lauren
and Trisha both gone in that area to
check but I heard Texan on the radio now
say he's seen I eNOS at the same spot so
maybe it's just the time of day not sure
but I know you would all like to see
Corky and plonk
and some of the new named hyenas one of
the newly named hyenas as well I haven't
seen June in ages I haven't see June in
so long okay well this is a very nice
area to check for tracks of sabri
intermingling with tandy up ahead
see what we can find and I would do that
seems like Tricia's found some birds
with their very own eyes I do have a
feathered friend now this is a very very
very big eagle oh it's beautiful I think
it may be there's a pier and I think
they may be Marshall Eagles the other
one I saw definitely looks like one
hello you guys and it was massive the
way you're seeing it now is just a speck
it's quite far awful it's going further
off but when we saw it just around Jay
it was massive
it was huge it's been there forever
since I saw a bird that sized against
that beautiful beautiful sky yes well
done myself
beautiful just watch that thing glide
through the air Marshall Eagles are big
birds they certainly uh look at that
against those clouds in that sky it is
unbelievable are you guys saying it's a
good one for your bird list certainly is
the martial eagle is wonderful it's a
nice big bird to get your your ID kind
of right with it it's got really nice
features like you saw that prominent
brown head and whitish chest in flight
and that's something that's really
really obvious okay well we have some we
have some other painted wolf you'd like
to know if it is a true eagle it is
certainly one of our true Eagles and
just want to go back and see the
vultures for a bit now the true Eagles
are of course Eagles that have yeah of
feathers modified feathers all the way
down their feet no you have some friends
yeah though it's been a long time since
I've seen my friends oh where did you go
friends are there you are it's a white
back Fulcher
so there's actually two of them hanging
about yeah there's another one in the
second tree same one packed voucher and
I'm wondering about why they're hanging
around yeah oh you wrote a white back
voucher how you
oh man get out of the way of the leaves
guys if you can ID him in this light
that is oh there we go
see another one right by now it's time
by nose time
oh really long cape brown head let's see
that see I'd love to see its back if it
would be so obliging
so these guys are quite big I must say
if you're looking at them in real life
they do look quite a big it could be a
Tony let's have a look
booted no war bags no where you Tony
there you are what definitely looks has
the Tony Eagle look
Barbara you also reckon it's a twirling
eagle yeah I am quite satisfied with
Tony Eagle as well so this is quite a
night spot we've got 220 Eagles in that
tree right there none of which are the
one that we saw this morning because the
one we saw this morning was kind of
slightly colored or was in betweens
colorations was a juvenile and then
we've had the Marshall Eagles in the
same area and the two white bat vultures
and that is interesting very very
interesting must be a big bird party I'd
like to see where they're looking
hello white back forger
mmm I love when you just see them fly
off any bird for that matter let's go
down further and see if that martial
eagle is still here
Monique did you ask if there are any
birds that use tools if I heard that
correctly I'm not sure my cell let's
move forward and check if that martial
Eagle is still there that was nice
oh yes that is what you asked you like I
feel like I've heard this mm-hmm yes
will you in fact Marcel and I were just
chatting about how smart Ravens and
crows are and they sometimes use tools
to assist them or things like they'll
put a tortoise if they catch there they
go there they go I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna park here no no no no no no this
will be tough this will be tough Marcel
you'll be a monster if you can catch
that
so the tadaa well done they flying quite
a bit I wonder what's going on now
Ravens and crows day sometimes they're
sometimes known to to use cars so
they'll puppet
exactly Puma they they've been known to
take pieces of things and then go and
slide down sort of banks before just for
fun they've been known to put tortoises
in the road and for cars to run over to
they can break them so they aren't
definitely birds that used tool there's
also birds obviously that use the sort
of natural environment around them and I
suppose in a way using the grass and
maneuvering it to make a nest is also a
bit of a tool we can get a bit of view I
can hear something rustling hmm recipe
ok I'm gonna try and figure out what's
going on here what my birdie friends are
doing but I'm glad you got to add it to
your list in the meantime I'll send you
over to Lauren and see how her following
of asana has gone well not much has
changed in the world of Hassan here he
is doing the exact same position with
his sleepy looking face but he does keep
looking around scanning the area and we
are getting to that sort of golden hour
my favourite where the light just shines
across the whole landscape and gives it
that golden glow which means of course
the Sun is starting to say it is still
up in the sky but it's starting to say
and of course this is hosannas praying
this is when our cat will get up and
will get mobile and probably start
moving around and potentially thinking
of hunting because he clearly wasn't
thinking about that earlier when the ROM
went past we seen something behind us
me one of the Impala rhymes went off
that way but I I definitely can't see
anything but it looks like something's
caught his attention
well Sammy caught his attention he's
looking but he's eyes are drooping you
know that way when you're so tired and
you're trying to watch a movie at night
and your eyes to swim in your head and
you cannot keep them open that looks
like what hassanis do No hi Devon
welcome to survive yes this is life this
is happening right now we are sitting
here with Hosanna this male leopard and
it's completely live and completely
interactive hence why things happen in
the most unexpected ways things happen
that we really don't expect of course
sometimes we all make mistakes even the
animals make mistakes like asana so yes
this is completely live and you are
welcome to and ask more questions which
we will do our very best to answer even
Rosana give you a little note there of
acknowledgement welcome Devon and of
course you have just joined us so
Hosanna is a male leopard that safari
life has actually followed since he was
a cub since he was a teeny tiny furball
and we have watched his cat grow oh he's
looking at the birds sing
and he is now almost three and a half
not quite his birthdays in February at
the very very start of February sees
almost three and a half years old and
he's not the only leopard we have around
here we have lots of his family members
around too
he's just gazing up at the sky no
nobody's ghetto I don't know if that's a
Tony Eagle that just went past us
earlier but there's a bird very very
high up in the sky and that's exactly
what he's giving it
everything's catching his attention
right now but if he didn't meet a hunt
last night and he hasn't really sort of
made any smacking attempts and he won't
be hungry he looked rather skinny when
he got up to do the toilet right in
front of our vehicle which was lovely he
does look like he's in need of a good
meal and of course leopards need about
well roughly five kilograms of food per
day but they don't have to have it every
day Laura's asking what the Inca who
must hear him if they if he made a kill
very good question because the animals
out here all have excellent senses so
potentially not if he made a kill that
ended up being very very silent but if
the same of the kill traveled in the air
to the increments were not too far away
and of course they could pick up on the
same husana actually has been seen as
many of you know been chased up a tree
by a lioness so of course they all
scavenge off one another hyenas get this
terrible reputation for being these
scavengers but I can assure you all the
Predators scavenge off one another right
here it's a free easy meal where they
don't have to spend any energy hunting
so of course if the Inca who must did
get wind of it literally the same felon
in their nostrils he could of course be
drawn to it especially if there was many
lionesses against husana one leopard
husana would definitely flee and the
lionesses would be able to come in and
steal for him it's not worth hosannas
life basically to take on the Inca home
a lionesses they're strong and
especially if there's more than one he
could risk serious injury or even worse
it could be fatal so he wouldn't do that
Hosanna would most likely flee so yes
and who must could indeed
the same if he made any sort of noise
they could also pick up on the noise but
generally leopards tried to make silent
kills so they tried to stalk and they
really focus on that element of surprise
of course if the impalas are barking
they've normally given the game away and
the leopard generally tends to walk away
because of skiing over otherwise they
try to do it yes they try to do it as
silently as possible for that reason to
avoid attract and any sort of unwanted
attention no just from lions but from
the hyenas also hyenas are notorious for
coming in and stealing from anything and
anybody they do also hunt on their own
no but they also do steel just like
kisana would steal and they normally see
it's a ratio of four to one so for
hyenas and one lion or a leopard until
the leopard or lion will give up so they
normally take on a couple of hyenas but
once it sort of reaches number four then
they generally wouldn't take on any of
those hyenas because it's not worth it
hyenas are also incredibly strong
resourceful and they equally have large
teeth and a very strong jaw but husana
knows that he's been through these Wars
and adventures and he's very aware of
what he can take on and what he can't so
even after his incident with and go home
once where he got chased up the tree
he's still here he's in the exact area
that tree was just oh maybe a hundred
metres behind us possibly I'm not very
good at judging distance but basically
we're in the exact same area where that
tree was so it hasn't put him off is
what I'm trying to see he's still around
for now
but generally we do tend to find that
when the liens are around and such big
numbers especially because liens are so
vocal the evoke us and the Inka Houmas
that we do tend to see our leopards a
little bit less they're either hiding or
they have crossed off into other
properties presumably because the Lions
are around what are you looking at boy
that sons really starting to get lore
now I can feel the temperature of the
air really changing though he's just
given you a beautiful look of the Sun
starting to set everybody's saying that
they can see he's hungry yes I think yes
of course to make hunts and stalk the
way he stalks going along the ground
like that it's not a natural gait so by
him jeunesse keeping his tummy low to
the ground bending his legs his shoulder
blades up that's expending a lot of
energy it's a lot of energy into
stalking and making potential hunts so
of course you will be hungry now wasting
all that energy and not replenishing it
he will absolutely need to eat soon know
just why I'm not gonna go anywhere I am
gonna stay with them and see if he gets
lucky and manages to make a kill so
while I wait and see exactly what this
boy gets up to it looks like Raja has
had some luck with the hyenas
no luck except luck in the slight form
came or very slightly claim in the form
of Steve so si said he saw some hyenas
around the same place that he had seen
them before so I'm going to head there
while he makes his way to the Lions
hopefully I'll be able to see cookie
because it's in that same area that
Steve saw them before sort of the
eastern area of the reserve where
ordinarily they're in the western sort
of quad quadrant or central and western
oh I love them no don't go No
hello gosh I really love them they're
both bobbitt sequestered and the black
color bar but but the black honor bar
would call I really really like which I
could never do to save my life I
couldn't do it
Oh beautiful
even with slightly grey clouds in the
background still absolutely stunning
there you go wipe your beak off and
clean yourself
yes well like birds start the day of
course with a bit of a bit of preening
and a bit of food a snack so - do they
close their day it's been a while since
I've seen them it's always nice there's
one that hangs out near camp but even
even that one I haven't seen in a while
Kristen Babbitt said all over at the
moment around camp they've joined though
the horn balls and the starlings and
terrorizing us when we're near the
kitchen
gorgeous anyway guys I've got to make my
way down there to the hyenas the spot
where the hyenas were seen because I
don't want them to go anywhere problem
is I suspect that they're where they are
may not because where Steve had them
last time I'm not sure if he had them at
the Dan site or they moved to add inside
so I want to get that as quick as
possible so I can see hello hello call
it Bob that she would follow us are you
gonna follow us no no you just above us
she'd never look up when there's a bird
above you because it most definitely
will take that opportunity to christen
you almost always happens that way
sometimes I've got a vet my eyes me no
don't don't don't
I am I'm having great bad luck so maybe
during TV show I could hope for a few
hours which I wouldn't find at all
tell if you'd like to know if
black-colored barbets are endangered
they're not I think they are not even
Lester that is vulnerable not threatened
it's probably the right word but to be
honest most of the most animals are in
decline anyway I think something like
ridiculous amount of species more than
50% in decline so it probably is in
decline er but it is not threatened but
that all all that threat and things like
that is linked a lot to climate change
and the way things have been going she's
not particularly great and how sneaky
was out with this one because this one
is pretty sneaky in my opinion now it's
not speaking anymore because I didn't do
it but a lot of these things are caused
by climate change and on this day in
1988 a very well-known scientist
why did I just I just thought I heard
something well see if you can get in
there so if you see there's a nice gap
in there next down to the more wanti and
I just thought I heard the beginnings of
like something's going to start soaring
and I was really hoping that it would
but alas not hmm okay I just I just want
to just stay here for 10 seconds just so
I can listen I'll talk to you while I
listen but it was James Edward Hansen in
19 1988 that had actually had this
discussion on climate change and the
problems associated with climate change
and that seemed to spark the whole
scientific community being involved in
the fact that it needs to be mediated
right now everything needs to mitigate
it right now and we need to have some
sort of plan in place cams satisfied we
need to definitely have some sort of
cannons place and
the amount of species that are going to
really really be affected by it is just
ridiculous it's a huge amount because so
meant so much of us is dependent on on
temperature if you go a few degrees out
of your normal body temperature you can
be a goner because your enzymes and your
proteins will all be denatured if it's
too hot
and once it's denature it doesn't come
back it's to generate a lot of those
benefits would be good but it certainly
would there's some she don't wanna be
that off there little bit less actually
has to be the same thing happens a lot
in the tropics anyway I will send you
over to Steve well while I make my wage
to where those hyenas possibly well and
hopefully when you get back I'll have
them there on the move and they headed
straight towards tree house damn so I
made that call to come back just in time
otherwise we would have lost them
problem is is if they decide to go to
treehouse dam and then head off South
again and they're going to leave the
property hopefully they hunt I think
they're looking hungry they're just been
jogging off to something but let's see
if we can follow them through here here
comes another female
very good very exciting lions on the
move sorry Craig I'm gonna have to
squeeze under this bush here for you
hello there we go is Ridge nose with her
belly hmm
do you know what's going on here there's
a few vultures here sorry Josh I'm gonna
get to you now if you vultures yeah
that's how the lines of jogged in here
they're probably you know they're busy
sniffing the ground over there just sure
yo how many lions are in the park
honestly couldn't give you that answer
art now it's a very good question
very good question lions are all around
something over there everybody just give
us a moment but it's not uncommon for
lines to follow vultures they even
looking up the tree where the vultures
were sitting so craggy oh sneezing and
hello beautiful cats oh they're gorgeous
look at all of them maybe they killed
something here this morning because
their trucks did come from this sort of
area and looking up the tree who the
vultures okay what do you guys have for
us they're also looking down the way
there I don't know what they've seen
they've got very good senses of smell
and hearing insight and this is
marvelous to cut all of in there one two
three four five six seven eight now nine
one of the male's is missing
I can't they're gonna come and lie down
over here now very good very good I
wonder if there's something there on the
floor they're all sniffing in a moment
before it's awesome yes go north that's
it ladies it's also possible that
because we saw the pride had sort of
joined up this morning coming from
different directions it's also possible
that some members of the pride made a
kill here and the ones that have been
walking very slowly behind are probably
involved in that that's why they weren't
too keen to move forward and now the
others after following the vultures
activity now decided to plop down one of
the things I like about winter is that
the Lions get up a lot earlier so Joshua
I'm not hundred percent sure how many
lions are in the Kruger National Park
I'll have to research that for you
Alice are far as I'm aware the
Birmingham boys are indeed the fathers
of all of the youngsters in the pride
and it was before my time but they were
the reigning dominant males for the last
few years which would make them indeed
dads make the group of them fathers who
exactly would be the actual fathers of
each Cub it's hard to tell sometimes but
sometimes you can actually see the look
on the Lions face you can kind of tell
who is dad is or if it's a male legacy
get a very similar main development to
dad a genetic traits passed on
okay do you hear people over there okay
I think there are people having a
sundowner Nancy a line picnic is
definitely an interesting affair they
don't normally carry much with them a
normally grab it along the way okay
ain't in that pier for a little bit and
then probably go down and have a drink
okay well hasana
he is probably also going to be having a
picnic at some stage let's go back over
to Lauren who is enjoying a sundowner
with the little chief
husana is indeed having a sundowner he
has moved yet again and he is perfectly
positioned himself on a termite mound
which gives him a great view or the
landscape perfect vantage point and of
course he is just looking around every
bird that soars ahead he checks it out
every movement that's happening in the
thicket it also has a look to see
exactly what it could be
typical husana always claiming up into
the praying position where that gorgeous
Sun sets behind him and we actually had
a question earlier about the Lions
attracting the lion's attention and it's
about somewhere between five and ten
percent of all leopard kills which
aren't too regular well in comparison to
amount of attempts that they make that
are actually stolen by lions especially
and also some other predators like your
high you know spot lines especially it's
somewhere between five and ten percent
so imagine every time you make yourself
a nice dinner and you put a lot of
effort into it and kill then of course
you lose it and someone comes along and
steals it from you it's not exactly the
best feeling in the world so luckily
hosana will know that he will know that
the other predators are around and that
is exactly why leopards do what they do
and hoist which we see on a regular
basis
leopards just making sure they just get
their pre other dead prey their dinner
up the tree even tinned Ghana the other
night with his Python which was just
incredible he knew he had to get it up
the tree as soon as darkness came
because they know exactly what will
happen it will attract normally through
st. it will attract the attention of
other predators in the area
two leopards on ostriches very
interesting question I don't believe
they do ostriches are far too big for a
leopard even obviously we don't get off
trees too often coming through here all
I think mashaallah had some epic silence
with them but they're too big and of
course the cake of an ostrich is
incredibly powerful one cake is enough
to completely kill a predator or even
rip the jaw right off the mouth so for a
leopard size even the heaviest meal
which would be up to about 90 kilograms
approximately 200 pounds they are about
I really don't believe they would go for
ostrich of course if it was a very very
young ostrich and it was maybe alone and
lost and wandering around and of course
they would seize that opportunity but an
adult ostrich would be far too big for a
leopard I have seen footage of lions
school for them however and it's a risky
risky business the lion is risking
potential injury potential death from an
ostrich they're extremely large tall and
very very powerful birds husana would
definitely not attempt an ostrich put it
that way now obviously I did spend some
time with the leopards up in the Mara
and every time we saw them with a kill
it was very similar to here they always
had Thomson's gazelles or Impala they
have to take down what a suti to their
size and strength and of course they're
solitary so lions can hunt cooperatively
in groups whereas leopards don't so they
can't take off well they can't bite more
than they can chew
let's see even although I'm sure their
eyes are too big for their belly and
they would love to take that something
like that of course they can't risk that
I would really not be a good idea look
at him just perfectly positioned they
are you are a photographer's dream asana
compared to the likes of Miss Randy and
Columba the past few days they are not
photographers dreams
well I'm sure they are but they are just
notoriously difficult to actually get to
see Stowe and let people take photos so
I'm whereas here Messiah is doing a
perfect job
Oh posing for all of us right on cue
and of course it's sunny he always
appears and hangs around on a Sunday
nancy's it's saying it's a lazy Sunday
yes I love lazy Sundays it was my
favorite day of the week of course
before I came out here and I forget
exactly what day it is
more details I even forget what month it
is sometimes but generally I do love a
lazy Sunday and clearly so does hasanah
Oh something has caught his attention
well it looks like he's positioned
himself perfect because he heard every
word I see and apparently Trish didn't
have hyenas but of course she's looking
very hard to find them so let's go and
get an update
I am on the move but let's have a quick
drive-by I'm actually going to scratch
around for some adults because when you
can have a look at them here we have two
cubbies yeah and in the thickness
helloyou it's one of pretties and then
one of June's at the back there I'm just
gonna drive about I'm still in the road
so I'm okay but I'm gonna drive on and
see if there's an adults around because
Steve did say that he saw an adult when
he came through here so let's go around
this Mound they seem to almost be in the
thicket or the sort of drainage at the
bottom there I'm just gonna check up it
this way
I'm just gonna push in here see if we
can see any movement Lauren you would
like to know which one of the Cubs has
et on it let's actually let me show you
the different types
so this one is Swasey pretties male cub
this is debated this one here looks like
the et one I haven't seen them in so
long so we have Swasey we have indi
Bailey plunk we all know plunk SWANA
okay sorry guys but we're gonna have to
go because this little one is getting
curious and walking towards the car even
though I've moved away from the den
excuse me do you have an adult present
see this is this is the problem this is
why we can't you're gonna get scared
when I start up hello it's basically
that the bonnet then it's gonna get a
very big scare no okay no we have to go
this one's out too sorry guys I'm gonna
have to scan you it's for your own good
mischief-makers see if they were there
are if they had a if we had an adults
around this would be awesome I'm just
trying to scratch it on and I'm he they
were all the way down that's I'm driven
on the road for a bit it still came this
way and that's why they're following the
vehicle and that is not a good thing
especially if there's no adult around
the older Cubs they're slightly better
because they're not gonna be by the den
anyway I'm talking about pretty and
pretty sync up and plunk but these small
ones those are the ones that I worry
about anyway I'm going to keep on trying
to figure out if there's an adult
anywhere around yet maybe just drive
drive the length of the road but in the
meantime I'll send you over to Astana
and Lauren since they seem to be having
a better luck makers hyena Cubs are
indeed and it's quite a few times now
we've gone to that saying we are we've
actually seen the Cubs of three of them
ribbons one and June's two and it's been
a beautiful moment a beautiful sighting
but of course we can't see there because
there's no adults around so what I'm
starting to feel is that they are
getting to that age where the mothers
are not returning every single day so
there's a lot of studies done that
analyzing the milk of hyena mothers and
it shows that they often do need to
spend time or we nourish in themselves
eating as much as they can
sorry I keep catching what's on his face
and it just makes my heart melt
I'm nourishing themselves as much as
they can and then of course they come
back and return in the this they will
suckle and this actually provides the
Cubs with a much higher energy level
nutrition fatty acids proteins all sorts
of things including calcium and so the
mothers do spend a lot more time away
from the Danes Wayne the Cubs get that
little bit older when they're very very
young especially in that black bear
stage of course they depend on the
mother quite heavily
similarly with cats or your lions and
the leopards they will be borne and
stashed away in a really secret den the
lioness will also move herself away from
the prey
and a leopard will find are really
really hidden den somewhere to keep the
Cubs until they're actually ready to
sort of face the world if you like and
lion cubs can even start eating meat at
around six weeks to train themselves to
sort of build up their immune system
practice eating but of course the mother
will continue to suckle for a little
while longer
after that so hopefully maybe if trehala
pops back later the adults might be
around i named of course we can spend
far more time in the day and if they are
and believe it or not we're husana is
right now is really not that far from
the danes not too far at all and not too
far from the lions either which is
really interesting
everything is in very close proximity to
everything else out here so of course
they will all bump paths more often than
not and we see sightings with husana and
hyenas regularly in it is rather
entertaining because they're not gonna
attack one another generally they make
their feelings known husana both snarl
he'll growl sometimes I you know even
snarls but generally they tend to just
avoid and ignore each other as much as
possible
how Sanne knows that hyenas are not a
threat to him but of course he will come
in and steal his kill but it's highly
unlikely the hyenas here would actively
hurt him himself they just want the
scraps of his feet oh Linda seen
something very interesting
hosana is losing his baby face you think
so I see what you mean he is looking a
bit more manly there's another vehicle
next to us and they're all not and
everyone agrees losing his babies he's
becoming a man
and of course that julep is getting
bigger nowhere near its biggest in
Ghana's of course but it definitely is
getting bigger he's really grown up
especially since he left even Tony's
mini vacation came back again and you
can definitely see a growth spurt in him
Kasana won't get any taller but there's
a high possibility that he will fill out
some more and of course that jewel app
once it becomes a dominant territorial
mill and he really starts scent-marking
and patrolling and having his own area
that says that jewel app will get bigger
and it's funny we just had a discussion
yet last night or possibly the night
before about Columba looking like st.
ghana and funnily enough I don't really
see it with husana I don't know what you
think but when I look at Hassan I don't
really see his father I see more of a
resemblance but in Ghana and Columba
than I do with Hassan Oh
I personally think asana looks more like
his mother but I could be wrong you're
welcome to share your thoughts with us
yeah I'm uh st. Andy yeah I know what
you mean I think it's the ears in the
eyes with Tandy I do see a resemblance
moreso Tandy than Singh Ghana for sure
but there's definitely a resemblance
they are I just can't quite put my
finger on exactly what it is
so husana is clearly not going anywhere
but Steve's lions are so let's send you
over to Steve
well the Lions were headed to treehouse
Dam for a drink I would suppose and then
they will lay down and now they have
turned and heading north we've just come
around onto the road so we don't have to
fumble through the bushes there and
they're gonna come through here at some
point is a herd of and parlour in front
of us and they're slowly moving through
here lovely to see them hunt I'm just
gonna give them some space I can't see
them just yet but Craig could see them
moving in this direction it's
interesting that a tawny eagle up the
tree with a small animal just a skeleton
that they're busy feeding on Charlie
universe it's a very good question we
really you never know if if males will
be chased away and at what age I mean
generally three is the sort of ballpark
figure but like I was discussing quite
at length this morning there's no set
rule behind that so it could be any time
now they might even stand up to the
vocal males the two of them you never
know you never know
I mean Craig you wear BOTS by this
Marilla you reckon we're just gonna
stand by here and let them be as
stealthy as there can be stealthy lions
I can't see them I don't want to lose
them of course I want to give them too
much time but they were headed in this
general direction to here so just want
to make sure we allow the Lions and the
prayer animals the benefit of the doubt
just move up onto that clearing here
Craig maybe we see didn't do that yet
yeah they're just coming across there
from that virility like you said just
saw movement
I love following Lions hunting it's
always one of those special things to
see how they coordinate their movements
with each other with almost no
communication just the position of the
ears are sort of the angle of the body
and they all know where to go watching
some of those hunts from the drone was
so so special if any of you remember any
of that just wish they spent more time
on the property I'm just gonna stand by
here no point going in there I'm sure
they're gonna come out and they're kind
of cutting through here towards where
the old end access is but they're sort
of trajectory is a sort of Norfolk and
they will move for hunting and then at
the same time they kind of know the
direction they're headed in we'll also
provide them with some water so Masana
you be where my friend the direction
they were headed is definitely in the
direction of your favorite spot
you see anything Craig mmm they're in
there everybody they're in me
don't freak out everybody or sauna has
seen lines before he will see them again
he and his can't have survived and
evolved with lions it is the way it
works it is the way it works he will he
will know the Lions are coming and we
will let Lauren know long in advance so
that everybody here can make sure that
they don't influence the sighting at all
very good well sure Sharla has managed
to catch up with not only the Cubs this
time it seems that one of the drew
Madden adult members has arrived an
adult has arrived how awesome is that
and it is in fact pretty girl and those
are height you know her one that is
coming out now now those shoes June's
one that has come out try and try the
luck as well no no that milk is not for
you it's the second time with him such a
long time it's also nice to see how much
they've grown up I mean they're hanging
out I'll chair by themselves and even
though this one is so big now it's still
squealing squealing full milk mum
now I think that I think this one is
actually pretty daughter
so she's pretty daughter her name is
Linda Bailey
so hello in do Bailey they're sitting
and enjoying your meal you know junior
than us in the picture now shift over
man I know that Jo is suckling your cub
at shift over I need to say hello Linda
you say it's so precious it's very very
precious Oh careful careful tuned
but look at how important it is this
whole greeting ceremony is so important
that it means that in an interruption
has to happen from the suckling even if
that means that June puts her face right
onto all right on to pretties nose to
say come on come and greet me now I have
a suspicion that in this drainage that's
in front of us it's only about five
meters behind that and then now it's
probably where there's a den site where
they're hanging out now the only one
who's yet to come that I really really
want to see is coqui coqui and ma plunk
haven't seen in forever
now it's interesting to watch pretty and
in develop suckling compared to when we
watch ribbon and paddy and how cute and
small pity is that she fits in right
against ribbon well this big and lanky
thing adorable though has to make a
space for its lanky limbs now and it's
just she just can't lie as close to
money
it is a wonderful moment I'm glad you
are enjoying it I'm glad that we managed
to find this so that's thanks Steve
because he came across them first
I wonder where Jun has settled down with
her too because I'd love to figure out
her too as well especially with their
thick shaggy coats it can be a little
bit difficult to tell them apart but I
think I can I think I'm not doing too
badly
hmm yeah I think this one is in the
Bailey
very sweet I'm so glad I got to see them
it's a shame that I couldn't actually
see them when it was still a lot of
light as for you as well because it's an
IR but oh well look at that he's always
she's always gonna push away from mom
you big little one yes even mom says
come on come on time to me that's
actually her complaining too mom at the
moment let's go around the other way
it can be quite difficult to hear but I
hope that you caught a little bit of the
squeal now this is quite a tricky
drainage because there's a huge thicket
there's a massive thicket bit oh well
we'll try out but while I reposition and
try to get in there see if there's
something in that drainage let me send
you over to Steve and his lions who seem
to be on the move well I'm happy to
accommodate Trish we went quickly to go
see if we could find this hyenas and
there with it and then we heard the
Lions were moving so we quickly rushed
back yet
and we've got this war talk yet and the
Lions are moving in this direction I've
had sight of one lion but they're all
slowly kind of moving this direction
I've lost its visual now but they were
all kind of heading in this direction so
we just have to keep our our eyes and
ears open this warthog is not in a very
good position a leopard would really
really struggle with the water with
tusks like that but all the pride of
lions they have the strength and the
numbers to teachers who rip it apart
before it's able to bring those tasks
into play they still would be quite
weary and quite cautious there but I
have lost all sight of these lines I
don't want to start my engine because
this warthog is going to run and he
might fall victim to the Lions he might
run away from the Lions and I don't want
it to be anything to do with me
sorry gonna be patient let this play out
Craig and I were just talking about when
we saw them goomer's kill that warthog
last year that was absolutely incredible
and the water doesn't seem to have any
idea you're our Timur but he's a termite
mound here might have come out of that
probably should go into it to be honest
with you okay I've got visual of that
lion Craig is just underneath that tree
and it's running okay
Lions are running
let's run past to the den site ok this
stop right there there's a line coming
atcha on my ride Craigie the lines are
all running everybody hold on this could
be quite bad for the warthog or whoever
they're chasing hold on they've come out
into the open they were hunting we don't
know what they saw before the warthog
another vehicle in the sighting
hopefully they saw where they went to
think they did we got a bit of - now
so we saw them running there and
straight past the Warthog I think
they've got something there's some in
parlor to the right hand side they might
have missed some Lions trying to move
around let's hitch off and listen if
they've caught something you will hear
it this lioness is coming back trying to
find out where everybody's gotten to
there's another one after they open
their nests I mean father right behind
us doesn't matter how many times you see
it everybody it can be quite thrilling
and also quite sad and my foot on the
clutch
even shakes I've seen it many times
Lions hunting many many times many times
they've killed ok they're going for the
Impala but the impala are way too quick
for them
grumpy old man hunting hunting hunting
well so I didn't want to move initially
because the warthog was there and then
they were chasing something else
completely then I saw another lion come
out of nowhere and I thought it was
going to catch that warthog we switched
off the Warthog got away
good warthog you ran with all of your
life I think that was the young male
that tried he doesn't quite have the
experience if that was a lioness I am
quite certain that that warthog would be
dinner right now shoo
well everybody one-nil to the warthog
but the lines have split up this happens
when they hunt they chase different prey
animals some of them were chasing in
parla one saw the warthog it wasn't a
coordinated attack the camouflage of
these animals and that well concealed
ability that they have and the Lions
splits up but that's why we were waiting
it's incredible we were waiting then all
we could see was one lion Barbara that
it was one lucky warthog and when you
see one line and the Lions all very
still and not moving that's a very good
time to just stop moving and do
absolutely nothing and then they started
running and well you saw the end result
there AIIMS
for the most part miss an enormous
amount Chris one of those two their jaw
man ago was indeed one of the young
males that you came from the back he had
no idea what was going on got another
one on that on the cut line there just
go up to her so we don't lose them
this is when it becomes very easy to
lose some lions because they start
splitting up and they will fight each
other through smell but if you lose one
you lose them all well comes another one
and you lose all of them and anyway are
we gonna take a breather and it's take
you over to Lauren and a sauna to see if
he's gonna get up to anything you will
not believe it we're sitting here with
hisana
and we have came across a hyena I don't
quite know which I you know this is but
we've came across a hyena lucky lucky me
so we can let Trish holla no that's we
find the hyena very nice and so in love
I did steal it from another vehicle but
I am completely in love with that but
husana is on the move to more important
matters there's Impala all around he's
been looking at them for some time now
but he's only move where is he going I
think we'll need to put some lights on
to actually see very scone you've got um
okay we're actually able to see a much
better if we take a look at the thermal
camera FLIR image we can actually see
them just popped up behind the termite
mounds but it's actually really
difficult to see them using the infrared
camera they're big or you can just see
them poke an eye behind the termite man
they are that hot oranjee blob is of
course husana never I can only presume
it's still the Impala we are losing
light rapidly here it's definitely gonna
be time for the spotlight some things
when you're scanning using the FLIR it
can actually be really difficult because
the trees also appear quite warm but I
think it's an Apollo
he's gone down typical Asano
am I trying to run the little bet read
possession and see if we can get a
better view for him I am gonna return
this hyena
are you ready thank you
and see if we can actually see it but
when it lock is official and anyway I'll
just turn on my many lights so that I
don't crash into anything and let's see
if we can see exactly what he's looking
at
yep Impala okay so I don't want to block
this or obscure this view I'm not gonna
turn my lights off my goodness is
actually really hard to see him in this
light got him there we go he's flat C's
right he's just positioned himself right
behind the bush there and he's obviously
watching out for the Impala up ahead but
again is quite some distance and of
course just cause of his position we are
obviously able to see it just a little
bit better on that thermal camera
because we're not using any artificial
light it's a little bit chunkier to see
him when we're just using the IR and he
is far away we positioned ourselves
together not interfering with his sort
of visuals and Amy we and he is on the
move look at that it's amazing seen him
cross to that dark background like that
and look how warm that tree is
I'm just gonna try and get a visual with
him with my own eyes so that we can try
and follow him and see exactly where
he's going or what he is up to he's
definitely heading for the Impala
unfortunately is quite far up ahead
right in the thicket is a little bit
thicker over this side and we're gonna
move and see if we can roll relocate and
get a better angle so we're gonna send
you over to Trish who really does have a
hyena I have managed to catch up with
them now they've been very evasive and
every time I go down to Jane and she's
and they come back up every time I come
back up and they want to go down but in
June it's looking much more comfortable
now and she's a lot happier that both
her cubs with her
each suckling lift up that leg mum give
us some more space I think I have a
figure out who's who yet now this one
that is suckling with the bum to Mum yep
that one against mom's tummy I think
that one is so toe and that's because of
a sort of distinctive kind of half C
similar to the one that plunk has on his
thigh and he's got a half seen this one
so taut he's got a half see on the right
right-hand side of the Nick says one
plus it's a lot darker now they're on
the left I think that one day is SWANA
and that's just by process of
elimination so you go hello it's Juana
and hello so - lovely to meet you all
with names
I'm always surprised to see that when
they're young when you have a set of
Cubs and they're very young and the way
they compete over space to be able to
suckle off mum it's really really highly
competitive always pushing and shoving
and scratching and biting but as they
get older it's almost as if that's top
sec they know their their place and I
suppose that is part of the whole
hierarchy system and actually being
constantly being made to be submissive
or really made to fit into we're really
Cokie wants you to fit in and once you
know where you're fit in
there's no issue it doesn't sound very
much like hyena rights movements are
rampant or because everyone's just got
to stick to their job be low-ranking if
you're low ranking but it works for them
now these Cubs about six months old and
I think they were first seen at the
beginning of this year oh I'm glad you
guys I feel nice to be back with him I
do too there was a bit of a teat swap
there where one went down other one went
up and then they decided no no he'll
return to their normal positions and
every now and then Jun's leg rest rests
on her little one which is quite funny
it's almost like she's doing stretches
she's lifting that leg up and covering
her little cub anyway let me send you
over to Steve because he's lions are
also quite fat a flat or not fat
it is my hyena that is fat they are
sitting down indeed we've only got
visual of three of them super happy you
able to have such a lovely sighting
there with all the little ones Trish but
we've got three lioness now they're all
in the open just listening they're half
of the pride tore off in a direction I
didn't really see where they went - oh
yeah we go two of them are coming just
on the rachac raided that big merida
tree and we are in the via sighting with
other vehicles and I can assure you if
they do hunt again will ensure everybody
goes lights down there we go you just
see the movement it's incredible they
just know where the rest are okay go up
they go time to follow wait are they
gonna head - so we're on the full moons
Kaplan with Weaver's nest and in part of
that they saw disappeared without an
alarm call there's net funny amaz
impalas are watching the Lions didn't
shot at them once this guy Craigie
where are they gonna hit - there's
anyone's guess really anyone's guess
hopefully not south hopefully on sap a
few more minutes of the show left good
evening ah
Nancy liens are not picky when it comes
to food meat is meat and a lion will eat
even he's rotten 10-day old meat if they
can and if they come across it but
they're definitely hungry they've been
sort of moving let me go to the junction
here that's the access to the old
hanging a den site don't want to get in
the way or anything and guide them in
whatever directions so I'm just gonna
park on the corner here rod
oh sorry Craig it's the problem when you
drive without lights you can't actually
see the bumps okay so they're gonna
slowly come down here bearing in mind
they also have also know that other
animals how the Lions are in there
somewhere and they're gonna try flush
some of those animals back in this
direction so they're going to move and
spread out a bit and sort of have this
net of waiting lionesses I have to do
this all the time the dirt without even
talking to each other they just see okay
ones gone there ones gone there how can
we tighten the net bless you in the
layup and wait that is one of the
advantages of lion prized is the ability
to to chase animals into that net
they'll often liven it up and then other
Lions will go around sometimes the
inexperienced ones would go around and
flush the animals towards them
these look like three adults to be all
fourth one fifth one no good
okay well while we watch to see exactly
what happens with our own Kahuna pride
Trish has taken a moment to look up
towards the Stars I am looking at the
sky and I remember we saw it Jupiter
yesterday and I showed it to you now
look at it because Marcel and I were
playing around with the camera
afterwards to see if we could get the
moons of Jupiter and the satellite and
there you go
I there's one really really close that
you can't see now and you can see that
there's three sort of in line with it's
now I'm not sure if these are all of
these are Jupiter's satellites I'm
pretty sure that the ones close by one
and two and either side of it must be
that's got four really I won't say
dominant but the ones that we know
really well I'm so used to talking about
animals and dominance but the four
popular ones that is er easily seen like
Europa Ganymede II and low end Callisto
of course how awesome is that naked eye
when the camera all the way from South
Africa there you go Jupiter and moons
I can't imagine anything nicer to be
above hyenas that are lovely and
suckling here Patra may be a full moon
but then we wouldn't be able to see
Jupiter very well would we know we have
a hyena puzzle going on yeah
they just seemed to be merged into one
big Hina
kantha so pathos you say that the
planets are aligned for our TV show I
think so
well maybe they were just a line so that
rashanna could see these hyenas that
I've been missing out on and all of you
it could be a line for us all it's a
really nice thing to be able to show
people though those moods cuz I remember
how excited I was when I saw it and
realized I could see it with my eyes I
didn't need some sort of special
instrument well I mean apart from a
camera with an excellent zoom lens but I
can also see it with my binoculars which
i think is just extraordinary reminds
you how small you are
Apsara I know exactly what you mean you
saying it something you're amazed that
we could actually see it that's how I
felt the first time I saw it and I
picked up my nose and I looked at them
and at the planet and I thought what and
there's one really really really close
to sort of the surface you could see
there's just a sliver between it and the
planet and it was just it was very
awesome to see so yeah if you know there
are planets that are rising in your
hemisphere and you know that they have
satellites or moons go ahead and take
your vinyls out and have a look and see
if you'll be able to spot it because you
may be pleasantly surprised like ours
Oh June June's not totally asleep but
she's looking really nice and relaxed at
the moment well I do know that pretty
was around and so her cubs
so I'm gonna stand around or wait around
you in just a little longer and in the
meantime I'll send you to Steve when
he's Lions and I'm gonna wait right here
well we've got seven then just keep
materializing out of the thicket stay
and one vehicle nearly photobombed
then has there drove past one two three
four five I counted seven it's amazing
how they can sort of melt in together
you can see they're all awake and that's
okay I'm glad you didn't catch them and
we'll all look like very weird in the
the IR light
so the lines are very alert you see how
they might look like there might be
quite sleepy but their heads are up and
they're listening they're very alert to
the sounds in the wilderness and they
would listen for the footfalls of any
prey that might be sort of daring enough
to come close
the others are probably still lying in
the thickets
Charlie the universe as some lion prides
get more experience in that the
youngsters become adults they learn
after years of hunting with the pride we
discussed it earlier to three years and
so they're regarded as adults they
learned in that entire time how it's
done and the lionesses are very very
skillful and they're very very good at
helping and they just know what to do
you'll have individuals that will know
to lay down the net and individuals that
will know to go around and chase and
it's very hard to know I don't really
know how they decide it's but they kind
of just look at each other and one
because you see the spots or the black
patches on the back of the ears because
you see those the Lions can see the
intention of the line in front and by
that intention that body posture they
kind of pick out the area or the angle
that they're going for and then they're
try and move around to try and help but
it's really really interesting to see
and in the few times we've managed to
film it from the drone it's been very
interesting to see how they've actually
gone all the way around after laying
down the net unfortunately sometimes the
net is not big enough or the animals
pick the line that just gets them out of
harm's way but if a youngster is maybe a
little bit too eager and chases the
Lions or the animals in the wrong
direction that can also sometimes cause
him to escape
I remember seeing a five or six
month-old Cubs chasing Impala into the
net that was provided by the parents
very successfully although we saw it
initially and it probably didn't happen
again for some time sometimes it's luck
the angle that the Impala run can be
quite sort of sort of varied and if they
do run directly at the waiting lions
they'll just let that fat and then
launch themselves as soon as one of
those Impala comes within reach well
what a wonderful evening we have head
and forget everybody and we're going to
be switching over shortly to go into the
SABC show so
please feel free to continue watching us
give us about half an hour I hope you've
enjoyed your afternoon hopefully uncle
homers will be active again and Lauren
will find husana and Joon's Cubs will
remain art in the open but until later
if you're not watching we'll see in the
morning otherwise you're an S abc3
goodnight and goodbye